so after all these years of video game
history they finally made the definitive
Western experience because it makes you
feel like a badass it's open-world point
is this game lets you kill a lot of
folks so let's talk about how fun that
is Red Dead Redemption so Red Dead
Redemption came out a few years ago but
don't worry it's not irrelevant it's an
open world like Grand Theft Auto but set
in the Wild West one could call it Grand
Theft Auto alpha actually so in Red Dead
Redemption you play as John Marston he
used to run with the really bad crowd
they were bandits then they shot him and
left him for dead now he's like hey I'm
gonna kill you pretty standard Western
male response we would even respond like
that these days if it were legal but we
live in a civilized society in which
case were like hey you left me for dead
well that's not nice I'm gonna call
9-1-1 but if you're John Marston from
Red Dead Redemption you go out there and
you gun down some folks John Marston
totally works because he ran with a bad
crowd but he's decided to be good so you
have the freedom of you can be a dick in
the game and blow people away or you can
help people and really either one would
work for his personality types all about
how you want to play the game which is
pretty standard in a game like this but
I'm just saying in this setting it
really does work to build your own
Western badass now in order for Red Dead
Redemption to work they would have to
nail a few things beginning but not
limited to you'd have to feel like a
badass and the game does exactly that
derp gun slinger if ever there was one
you get upgrades and weapons yeah that's
all cool but who are we kidding it's all
about the revolvers give me the cult's
the double action that [ __ ] shoots fast
you start getting semi-automatic SATA
points like here use this like no I'm
playing a Western to use this so I'm
gonna use this fills more Western why
would you give that up this being a
Western game gun fighting is an
important part of it if the gun fighting
sucks the game is going to suck that's
just the way it is luckily the gun
fighting is pretty badass at first yeah
you just shoot people down that's it but
you start getting something called
Deadeye in which case you push the
button and everything slows down people
large from
and you move your cursor over to them
you push r1 you tag them you can tag a
point of anything you can shoot for as
many bullets are in your chamber you
have a six shots like one two three four
five six tag make them all headshots
pull the trigger your dudes just
everyone gets shot in the head level
yeah that is called a video game making
you a badass gunslinger and just like in
Grand Theft Auto you're on your main
campaign but you run into people who are
like oh hey can you help me you're like
yeah sure other people are like I don't
like the way you look at me boy as me
spitting all western style they do that
stick into a duel a showdown with him
you raise your gun you shoot them before
they shoot you sometimes you just walk
out of a building you see some dude
trying to knife a chick you're like huh
uh-uh not in my town not in any of my
five towns Johnny Drama Entourage and
you can get different outfits in the
game but who are we kidding I myself got
the deadly assassin outfit and I just
stuck with that the outfit looks like
this this is what you look like more or
less is there really any reason to get
any other outfits look this is badass
this dude just looks like he kills
people looking like this is my kind of
western Red Dead Redemption really does
not have a lot going against it if
there's one gripe is that you kind of
wish there was more stuff Grand Theft
Auto you're in a city and every street
corner there's there's just buildings
and [ __ ] everywhere in Red Dead
Redemption there are long stretches of
just wilderness wilderness and brown and
vultures flying above you but it totally
works it's the Wild West and
surprisingly that really does engross
you into this Western world so the one
gripe I can think of in my head is
actually a positive for the game because
it makes it feel like the Wild West so
it's not a gripe at all it's not a
negative not only is the terrain really
diverse and really immersive but the
towns are really diverse also some towns
have civilization other towns you're
like no that's like Deadwood I went on a
spree I walked out of the saloon I was
like why not took my shotgun BAM just
started blowing dudes away because
everyone does that in a game like this
every open-world game you go on a murder
spree just to see if you can get away
with it I was not wanted by the law
really I was like wow this is this is
just a lawless piece of [ __ ] town god
bless you being in a Western game town
of course in a game like this not all
the missions are gonna be cool you go to
this ranch like oh hey can you rustle
some cattle you're like wrestle cow
really lady look at me I clearly look
like I kill people I do
people I'm a gunslinger dude wearing an
outfit called deadly assassin you want
me to wrestle your cattle no all right
I'll do it but I'm not gonna like it
Big Damn hero ain't I just in the end of
the game when you're getting your
revenge or like oh this is awesome the
game climbs the ending happens but it's
not really the ending because there are
a few more missions to do after that and
the game is like oh yeah you're not done
by the way could you wrestle that cattle
please you're just like is this a joke I
did all that my story was coming to a
head and now to kill it off I need to
rustle cattle you're just trying to piss
me off aren't you and you have a few
missions to do after what you would
consider the end of the game but I was
thinking these missions should be
post-credit missions however I'm a
really hasty person I know that about
myself so I was like alright I'll give
it a shot we'll see where this goes and
in the end I'm actually glad of it and
it does have a point in purpose if you
love westerns there's no reason not to
play Red Dead Redemption
my friend was always like you're a
Western fanatic and you love open-world
games I'm gonna put Red Dead Redemption
here for you so when you play it like
you should you will thank me thank you
Adam you're the man Red Dead Redemption
is the definitive Western experience and
one of the best open-world games I've
played it is awesome tacular
right in terms of open-world game what
is your favorite open-world game or if
you don't like open-world games
favorite Western whatever they would be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more